[Musique]
comment repérer les faux commentaires
pour naviguer dans la mer de produits et
de services sur internet le consommateur
s'oriente avec les étoiles mais il peut
faire fausse route le bureau de la
concurrence du canada a évalué en 2010
est qu environ le tiers des avis en
ligne et fo par exemple des entreprises
demandent à leurs employés écrire de
faux avis positif d'autres achètent les
faux avis en payant moins un ou deux
dollars par commentaire d'autres encore
sous droits des consommateurs en leur
offrant des gratuités ou des rabais en
échange des toiles mais les vieux loups
de mer qui savent naviguer ont des trucs
ils recherchent les commentaires
détaillés qui montre les deux côtés de
la médaille le signe que de vrais
consommateurs les ont écrits il se méfie
lorsqu'il n'y en que des avis 5 étoiles
et presque aucun avis négatif personne
n'est parfait dans la vie mais surtout
ils savent qu'il ne faut pas se fier à
quelques avis seulement alors devenez
explorateurs voci naviguer sur plusieurs
plateformes et demandez conseil à votre
équipage parce que les avis des proches
sont précieux passés le mot
[Musique]